[Musique]
l'esclave l'être humain voilà le thème
du colloc organisé à l'occasion du
tricentenaire des lettres patentes qui
ont transposé à la Réunion les règles du
Code Noir organisé sur 4 jours par
l'association historique international
de l'océan Indien ce colloque a été
inauguré ce mercredi 22 novembre dans
l'hémicycle du Palais de la source en
présence de la vice-présidente du
conseil départemental Béatrice sigismo
on a donc des universitaires on a des
chercheurs des représentants donc de la
société
indianocéanist est présent lors de ce
colloque et bien entendu on va avoir des
échanges pour approfondir encore plus
nos connaissances sur le sujet la
question profonde qui se pose c'est
comment construire une société plus
juste une société plus égalitaire et une
société plus humaine parce que c'est un
sujet qui reste d'actualité 4 jours de
réflexion et de débat qui font partie
intégrante de la programmation du Grand
20 décembre organisée chaque année par
le
[Musique]
département